ont beaucoup de plaisir à vous
accueillir madame la ministre
aujourd'hui avec michel qui est présenté
d'autres collègues qui vont nous
rejoindre en visio depuis quelques mois
nous ont dit ce nom avec ma collègue
monique lubin beaucoup d'intervenants et
donc nous avions à coeur naturellement
de vous recevoir monique prend ses
auditions très à coeur vraiment un
travail de fond qui est fait beaucoup de
questions avec voilà différents volets
qui sont abordés ce matin nous étions
encore à gennevilliers pour une séquence
découverte qui était vraiment très
intéressant sur les sites et sur les
sites éducatifs donc nous apprenons
énormément de choses il ya énormément de
débats des changes avec parfois même des
idées contradictoires mais c'est aussi
ça qui est qui est intéressant avec
voilà aussi une volonté comme je vous le
disais juste avant de deux d'avoir un
panel large de la jeunesse de je le dis
surtout pour monique et michel de 0 à 3
ans voilà une attention toute
particulière est peut-être pour moi et
d'autres collègues
peut-être un peu plus d'accès sur la
tranche 15 25 avec notamment en
parallèle de nos travaux de cette
mission
la proposition de loi sur le ticket
restaurant étudiants qui est une
proposition qui me tient
particulièrement à coeur à qui fait
preuve aussi de solidarité envers les
étudiants qui n'ont pas accès au
restaurant universitaire avec une
volonté territorialisée justement les la
restauration étudiante avec un
partenariat avec différents acteurs mais
ce n'est pas là le le sujet même si
c'est l'actualité du sénat je vous
propose de rentrer dans le vif du sujet
de vous laisser la parole
merci en tout cas merci beaucoup
monsieur le président madame la
rapporteure
madame la sénatrice meunier moi ça me
tenait à coeur qu'on a suivi en fait les
travaux de vote de votre commission
également et c'est j'espère que ces
échanges seront les plus complets les
plus explicites
évidemment dans ses propos liminaires on
a essayé de présenter un ensemble un
ensemble d'éléments et que je pourrais
évidemment compléter après pour les
questions donc j'essaye de j'essaie de
faire synthétique et en même temps un
peu l'exhaustif alors
un exercice d'équilibré ce qui est
certain c'est que cette crise est là
évidemment bousculer les jeunesse et
quand je dis les zones s et les tranches
d'âge de manière très différente mais
également des jeunesses qui ont vécu
cette prise en fonction du lieu où ils
la vivent et la situation de leurs
familles la situation de leur territoire
s'il était en situation de décrochage ou
en étude et je crois qu'il était
important de regarder l'ensemble des
difficultés pour pouvoir répondre le
plus largement possible à ce qu'a révélé
plus fortement encore en fait cette
crise même s'il y avait un enfant un
ensemble d'éléments de on s'est dit
enfin de quoi on parle
aujourd'hui on a 12 millions dans notre
pays d'adolescents et de jeunes adultes
c'est effectivement le redire la tranche
d'âge sur laquelle je travaille le plus
c'est des collégiens et des lycéens
c'est des étudiants bien sûr des fois en
situation de décrochage des jeunes
actifs ou des jeunes qui sont à la
recherche d'un emploi ceux qui ont la
chance d'avoir une famille et ceux qui
ont une famille en situation de
défaillance également et face à ces
multitudes de situation j'ai pris
l'habitude de parler des jeunesses pour
en omettre aucune et au contraire
accompagner l'ensemble des situations en
prenant en considération qu'à cet âge il
ya beaucoup de transition et ses
transitions elles sont elles sont dues
effectivement à cet âge de jeunesse mais
quand on est jeune c'est le moment où on
a le questionnement sur ses études c'est
le moment qu'ont à l'entrée sur le
marché du travail pour certains d'autres
moments où il faut il faut aller vers
cette autonomie financière ou simplement
les difficultés par exemple d'accès au
logement
toutes ces transitions amène pour
certains des difficultés et donc entre
16 et 30 ans si je vais un peu plus loin
c'est le moment de plein plein plein de
transition ce qui multiplie les les
réponses et les deux ment et les besoins
d'accompagnement je pense que la
responsabilité que nous avons
aujourd'hui évidemment d'accompagner les
les les transitions les réalités et de
remettre peut-être au coeur au coeur de
l'ouvragé
cette promesse républicaine qui est
celle de l'égalité et surtout je sais
qu'on parle beaucoup d'égalité des
chances
moi j'aime l'expression d'égalité des
possibles parce que les lignes de départ
sont pas les mêmes bien sûr mais mais
l'action publique l'action politique
doit pouvoir amener accompagné au
maximum pour que les possibles et les
chemins soit concret et puisse puisse se
construire il ya ya pendant cette crise
peut être des éléments qui sont
ressortis plus fortement que d'autres
on a entendu des tensions entre
générations on a entendu de
l'individualisme on a entendu beaucoup
de choses de ce type là c'est parce que
j'ai vu vous parliez de votre de vos
déplacements sur le terrain et des
rencontres mois les genêts ce que j'ai
vu pendant cette crise elles étaient
pour certaines en grande difficulté pour
d'autres extrêmement engagé est un
exemple un chiffre qui me tenait à coeur
pour illustrer cette vivacité de
solidarité dans notre jeunesse
quand le gouvernement a lancé le site
dead
c'était le je veux aider point gouv.fr
élus 350 mille inscriptions et je crois
que c'est important de le rappeler plus
presque la moitié c'est plus vraiment
plus de 45 47% de ses inscrits avaient
moins de 30 ans et pour beaucoup c'était
un primo engagement c'est sûr qu'ils
n'avaient pas d'engagement bénévole
traditionnelle dans une structure au
delà de ça au delà de je pense être né
citer de rappeler qu'on a une jeunesse
qui s'engage
parce que c'était ouvert dès 16 ans
c'est pour ça que c'était intéressant de
regarder également +2 58%
c'est plus de 58 milles missions de
service civique donc de jeunes qui
étaient déjà dans un engagement accepté
de changer leur mission de s'adapter et
au contraire ont été extrêmement
proactif cependant après je pense avoir
salué cet engagement qu est réelle il y
avait il y a des difficultés il y a des
conséquences et de pauvreté et de crise
aujourd'hui on a un jeune sur cinq qui
vit en dessous du seuil de pauvreté dans
notre pays
on a également des difficultés
absolument structurelles 14 % des jeunes
sont ni en emploi ni en formation et le
chômage des jeunes est le double du
chômage en fin de vie repas traditionnel
mais du chômage
rien dans notre pays les conséquences de
cette crise elles sont aussi d'ordre
humain et pour le coup il se trouve
qu'on émet un petit échange informel
avec la sénatrice meunier et j'ai
rappelé les échanges qu'on aide que j'ai
pu avoir à klein philosophe assez connu
me connais beaucoup le les jeunes boris
cyrulnik qui est à souligner l'impact
psychologique pour les très jeunes mais
également pour les adolescents dans
cette période de crise sanitaire donc
des crises et que des crises et des
conséquences psychologiques un impact
également économique avec principalement
l'arrêt brutal des petits boulots qui
accompagne et principalement la vie
quotidienne de beaucoup de jeunes de
jeunes étudiants ou même de jeunes
actifs qui complétait en réalité un des
parcours par exemple de formation cette
crise sanitaire a des conséquences
sociales économiques et donc du coup des
conséquences sur l'avenir des jeunesses
et à partir de là la première des
actions a été évidemment de mettre en
oeuvre avec rapidité le plan un jeune
d'une solution ou j'entrerai dans le
détail mais ça a été une réponse d'abord
à cette crise dès 2017 l'action plus
largement du gouvernement elle était en
priorité de baisser le chômage pour
permettre l'accès à l'emploi un maximum
de jeunes et de baisser ce taux auquel
on enfin je pense qu'il ne faut
absolument pas s'habituer et ça a été la
mobilisation
juste en quelques chiffres sans être
absolument exhaustive mais de quinze
mille 15 milliards d'euros entre 2018 et
2022 pour la formation de plus d'un
million de jeunes et personnes qui sont
de jeunes en situation les moins
qualifiés la multiplication aussi de la
deuxième chance l'esprit de la deuxième
chance celle qui va aller chercher ceux
qui sont en situation de décrochage et
notamment avec une politique très
particulière je le souligne sur les
jeunes qui sont en outre-mer qui ont
aussi des particularités territoriales
et monsieur le président là je rejoins
vos propos propos liminaires sur la
réponse territorialisée et donc il ya
évidemment il faut avoir un regard
territorialisée aussi et ensuite je
pense évidemment à quelques avancées
sociales importantes l'obligation
scolaire entre 16 et 18 ans ou encore la
réforme professionnel qui a permis de
soutenir et je pense d'accélérer
c'est l'apprentissage qui est pour le
coup un engagement assez fort parce
qu'il permet un lien social une un accès
au marché du travail mais surtout
d'accélérer l'égalité des chances au
sens où il y a une relation humaine avec
son avec son maître d'apprentissage
là l'objectif est la vision du
gouvernement en tout cas de auquel
j'appartiens c'est lever les freins à
l'égalité des chances
à chaque endroit et donc pour le plus
jeune âge parce que je sais que ça
intéresse particulièrement madame la
rapporteure et madame la sénatrice dès
le plus jeune âge c'est évidemment le
plan des mille jours de mon collègue
adrien taquet du coup qu'il maîtrise
beaucoup plus le le 0 3 ans et est dans
le cadre de mon ministère aujourd'hui vu
que je suis au sein de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse et des sports
c'est également le dédoublement des
classes de cp et de ce1 avec des projets
comme évidemment les sites et une
éducatrice que vous avez visité encore
ce matin mais aussi je pense au
dédoublement des évidemment des classes
l'éducation prioritaire ou encore la
détection renforcée des situations de
difficultés sociales qui ont des
conséquences sur la les orientations des
mesures d'urgence ont été prises
cependant sur la question de la crise
des mesures d'urgence c'était 150
millions qui ont été versés avec
lunettes de 200 euros à plus de huit
cent mille jeunes mais de manière
ponctuelle c'était vraiment la réponse à
la crise et ces mesures elles ont
évidemment été complété en décembre
parce que cette crise a duré beaucoup
plus longtemps est la durée dans le
temps elle a duré plus de 13 mois et
donc ça a été une aide de 150 euros pour
plus de quatre cent mille jeunes
bénéficiaires des appels et des
étudiants boursiers ce qui rejoint
monsieur le président vos propos
également liminaire de comment on
élargit en touchant plusieurs jeunesse
sans être dans un statut uniquement et
sens opposé jeunes en études jeunes en
recherche d'emploi jeunes en situation
de décrochage est au contraire aller
vers quel vers une vision plus universel
de la politique de la politique jeunesse
je vais pas rentrer dans le détail mais
la volonté a été également de porter et
de stimuler les créations d'emplois sur
les lieux où il ya les étudiants je
pense aux 20000 job de twitter sur les
sur les crous qui était portée par ma
collègue frédéric vidal au delà de ça le
plein jeûne est une solution aujourd'hui
c'est une ambition qui est aujourd'hui
atteint les 10 les 10 milliards d'euros
alors que ça a été budgété au tout début
autour de 6 6 7 7 milliards parce que
les mesures du plan jeunes solutions ont
été renforcés rallonger dans le temps
parce qu'elles vont jusqu'au mois de
décembre en grande majorité avec des
mesures extrêmement diverses des mesures
qui soutenait l'emploi bien sûr parce
que soutenir les entreprises c'est
soutenir leur emploi et donc ces prêts
protéger les plus jeunes dans
l'entreprise
malheureusement connaître aux cet adage
alors un adage populaire mais qui est
réel dernier arrivé malheureusement
souvent premier sorti et pour préserver
ces emplois là ça a été le très
largement une mesure de droit commun
mais le chômage partiel largement
accompagné ou encore des simulations des
stimulations pardon à recrutement et là
je pense particulièrement aux aides de
versements de 4000 euros pour les moins
de 26 ans qui ont poussé et qui ont
permis d'atteindre quasiment 5 millions
de contrats signés entre entre
les contrats d'apprentissage et les cdd
long ou cdi au delà de ça ce qui est
portée vraiment plus particulièrement
chez moi c'est l'émission d'engagement
les services civiques avec 100000
missions supplémentaires ou encore des
emplois pour soutenir le monde
associatif qui accompagne lui-même les
jeunesse de notre pays avec plus de 2000
emplois frange est au delà de ça et je
veux pas être dans une dans un dans une
liste de mesures
mais moi il ya un combat qui m'a tenu à
qui me tient à coeur et qui m'a
peut-être franchement bousculé à mon
arrivée dans mon ministère c'est la
lutte contre le non recours quand je
suis arrivé dans mon ministère
j'avais j'ai une lecture très large de
toutes les aides tous les dispositifs
il y en a beaucoup sauf que le non
recours était est extrêmement important
et reste extrêmement important et donc
pour lutter contre le non recours il
fallait absolument commencer un
processus
évidemment d'universalisation mais
également de renforcement et de
faciliter l'accès à l'information le les
difficultés d'accès à l'information font
qu' il y à des reproductions
d'inégalités et elles sont
malheureusement beaucoup trop renforcée
c'est pour ça que avec et grâce à la
mobilisation de plusieurs ministères
mais de la direction que vous avez
auditionné déjà de la jeff bock
c'est mon administration on a créé on a
lancé il ya quelques quelques mois
maintenant
enfin il ya un peu plus d'un mois la
boussole des aides qui est un outil d'or
de point d'entrée alors c'est pas encore
parfait mais c'est de la première étape
qui permet à chaque jeune
après avoir répondu à un certain nombre
de questions se dire entre trois et cinq
minutes en fonction du site et de la
situation d'avoir déjà sept premières
informations de tous les droits auxquels
ils pourraient prétendre pour lui
faciliter cette première démarche sans
qu'ils aient à aller sur plusieurs sites
puisque on sait que c'est un frein est
un frein réel le non recours et c'est un
mal français mais alors totalement
endémique
sauf que chez les jeunes ça a des
conséquences encore plus graves ça c'est
pour le coup une certitude une certitude
au delà de au delà de la boussole dz
l'idée de réunir sur sur ce site un
jeune une solution des réponses au fur
et à mesure les réponses sur les stages
la réponse de jobs d'été les les
réponses d'accompagnement
venez renforcer bien sûr l'engagement du
ministère de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse qui a tout fait tout enfin
fait un maximum pour garder les écoles
ouvertes puisque les écoles ouvertes
permettait évidemment durant cette
période qui a été sanitairement
difficile de garantir un maximum d'accès
évidemment à l'éducation et au delà de
ça à un accompagnement social sans
laisser chaque jeune face
malheureusement à l'hybride ou dans une
cellule d'eau dans une cellule familiale
qui est des fois été plus difficile le
choix qui est qui est le nôtre
c'était également de conjuguer ça avec
un engagement extrêmement fort auprès du
monde de l'animation socio-éducative de
l'éducation populaire qui a un vrai
acteur est un acteur qui est aujourd'hui
renforcée alors que c'était
historiquement peut-être pas toujours
très simple mais la volonté du ministre
de l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanc car en ayant ce ministère
éducation nationale jeunesse et sports
c'était aussi de d'accompagner l'enfant
dans toutes les durées et tous les
moments le temps de l'école le temps
périscolaire le temps extrascolaire et
de coordonner et donc du coup de
conjuguer l'éducation formelle et
informelle pour en faire le meilleur
c'est dans ce sens que nous avons
développées vacances apprenantes qui a
été d'abord créer effectivement la
réponse de la crise en 2020 et qui a été
renforcée est reconduit cette année pour
plus largement avec en particulier moi
j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur les cô loa
prenantes
c'est vraiment le périmètre qui qui est
le mien j'ai évoqué l'accès à
l'information au delà de ça il ya des
travaux pour les accompagner le réseau
je pense évidemment
alors il ya beaucoup de sigles les
crises les piges les bij
mais c'est des lieux d'information etc
des lieux où il y à un accompagnement
pour les jeunes il y a il y quand je
parle d'accompagnement je peux pas ne
pas évoquer le l'action qui est
aujourd'hui menée avec un jeune un
mentor qui réunit des associations qui
travaillent autour de la question de
l'accompagnement humain et du coup des
situations de mentorat et tutorat la
réussite ne passe que par une relation
humaine construite et aujourd'hui on a
réunis dans un collectif mentorat
des associations qui faisait du mentorat
à différents à différents moments de la
vie les très jeunes par exemple je pense
à une association que j'ai appris à
connaître socrates qui use et des
lycéens qui accompagnent des collégiens
ou plus largement des associations qui
sont plus plus connu plus plus anciennes
comme l'a fait voter les mac ou enfin je
ne peux pas conseil cité parce que sinon
je vais en oublier je risque d'en vexé
mais le collectif mentorat s'étaient
portés avec un budget de 30 millions
d'euros
aujourd'hui le passage de 25000 jeunes
jeu 25000 jeunes mentonnais à 100000
cette année et 200 mille l'année
prochaine c'est l'ambition qui nous est
donné toujours dans l'idée est cette
volonté de lutter contre les inégalités
d'accès à l'égalité des chances réelles
en tant que projet projet de société
il ya deux il ya deux moments il ya
évidemment un moment qui est
particulièrement fort et qui va vivre
pour la première fois son sa réalisation
partout sur le territoire je pense au
service national universel que je porte
plus particulièrement qui réunit des
jeunes entre 15 et 17 ans cette année
ses vingt-cinq mille jeunes qui vont
être accueillies avec sur tous les
territoires et il y aura un centre dans
chaque département c'est la première
fois que notre pays.le le fait l'idée
c'est évidemment détecter les situations
les plus en difficulté et apporte un
accompagnement personnalisé
mais c'est aussi avoir un temps un temps
de creuset républicain et permettre le
départ le départ au du plus grand nombre
ça va dans l'esprit d'un pas être pas
des vacances pour tous en tant que tel
puisque c'est un projet vraiment
pédagogique mais ça permet une rencontre
des jeunesse de notre pays
en conclusion puisque j'ai déjà été
beaucoup plus longue que ce que je
souhaitais la crise je crois elle nous
elle nous a mis une face à des
responsabilités d'accompagnement de
plusieurs facettes des difficultés de
nos jeunesses en fonction de leur âge
bien sûr mais également en fonction de
leurs aspirations
est ce que nous je pense nous ce que
nous pouvons faire et c'est là la
responsabilité que nous avons alain au
moment où on se parle sert permettre
l'élan la reprise et de corriger les
inégalités qui ont été accentuées ou
creusé par cette crise en particulier
sans arrêter les transformations
structurelles et je pense à
l'information jeunesse qui pour moi est
un
je dirais teint est un vrai combat parce
que ça permet vraiment de ne pas laisser
la place au hasard
ce mot hasard reste quand même pas je
trouve d'une extrême violence
alors je ne vais pas parler des
mobilités mais il se trouve que j'ai
j'ai mobilisé l'office franco-allemand
et l'office franco québécois de la
jeunesse pour être prêt à repartir et à
permettre à toutes les fins à des jeux
nes avec des profils différents de
partir en mobilité puisque parce que
c'est une chance grâce en plus haut à la
1re budgets accrus et renforcer sur
erasmus plus ou sur le corps de
européenne solidarité qui est encore
trop peu connu et qui permet à des
jeunes qui ne sont pas en études qui ne
sont pas en situation je veux dire de
mobilité universitaire est bien de vivre
une mobilité internationale et pour le
coup c'est une c'est une chance sans
être plus longue monsieur le sénateur
mesdames les sénatrices je crois que
dire que la vitalité de notre pays c'est
notre jeunesse et que regarder la
multitude de ses richesses et la
multitude de ces deux de ces difficultés
nous oblige je pense à en faire une une
priorité collective et d'avancer sur des
réponses immédiates d'urgence sans
oublier la nécessité d'avoir des
politiques universelles en tout cas
c'est celle là c'est le projet que nous
portons
je vous remercie merci monique
tout d'abord madame la ministre merci de
participer d'être d'avoir répondu
favorablement à notre invitation
alors moi je vais rentrer dans le vif du
sujet puisque ce matin dont nous étions
à la cité éducative de gennevilliers
c'était particulièrement intéressant
c'est une expérimentation
que se passera-t-il à l'issue des trois
ans étant entendu que trois ans c'est
trop court
on nous a bien expliqué ce matin qu'il
avait bien fallu une année pour mettre
toutes les choses en place
donc là c'est la première année il en
reste il reste à peine un an et demi ce
cette période de trois ans et sera juste
suffisante j'ai envie de dire pour que
les acteurs le remplissage n villiers
ils se connaissent déjà ils
travaillaient déjà ensemble ce n'est
peut-être pas le cas dans toutes les
cités éducative donc est-ce que vous
avez déjà commencé à travailler sur
l'avenir de ces sites et éducative alors
je sais pour ça mais centris il se
trouve que j'ai pas la réponse exacte
pour vous dire c'est que c'est
pérenniser ou pas par contre ce que je
peux vous dire de manière extrêmement
concrète c'est la volonté aujourd'hui du
ministère du coût de l'éducation
nationale est d'accompagner ses
alliances territoriale alors elles
prennent plusieurs formes effectivement
la cité éducative et ça va dans le sens
de la de l'organisation ministériel
jeunesse sports et éducation nationale
donc tout ce qui va dans ce sens a
plutôt vocation à être accompagnés
préservé mais je peux pas prendre pour
le coût d'engagement à la place du
ministre de l'éducation
tout ce qu'il ya d'autres questions
je pense que vous avez eu des questions
c'est ça chez ces dames on a envoyé des
questions
la première des questions elle portait
sur la multiplicité des acteurs qui
interviennent en direction des jeunes
effectivement nous arrivons nous au
terme de ce travail et la sensation que
nous avons
c'est que il y a multitude d'acteurs
quels que soient les sujets d'ailleurs
que nous avons abordés ou plutôt les les
les âges ce que notre mission elle va de
0 à 25 enfants de 0 à 18 ans va dire à
l'entrée dans la vie active
nous avons rencontré beaucoup d'acteurs
pour la plupart très engagé et
passionnant et nous avons peut-être
l'impression à la fin que il y a
beaucoup de choses et pas assez
coordonnés c'est un peu un maquis
qu'est-ce que puisque vous que vous
répondez à ça mais l'ama sénatrice votre
votre constat il est partagé
il est totalement partagé c'est pour ça
que l'idée typiquement de des sites
éducatifs c'était ça c'était réunir les
acteurs mais au delà de olza de manière
très concrète
il ya une nécessité de coordination
réelle au niveau ministériel on a
constitué ce fameux paul qui était
souhaitée par l'administration nationale
qui réunissait déjà plusieurs temps de
l'enfant pour que les politiques qui
touchent pour le coup la jeunesse et là
je suis plutôt sur ce que vous disiez
1,01 plutôt trois d'ailleurs pour être
plus juste mais 3 3 18 ans voire un peu
plus ce soit au tour déjà d'un même pôle
ministériel et donc c'est comme ça qu'on
rassemble la vie associative
l'engagement le sport et l'éducation
évidemment mais il ya aussi eu la
réforme votée qui est applicable depuis
le 1er janvier alors un sigle un sigle
encore hot et aux organisations
territoriales de l'état qui a permis de
rassembler des administrations de
l'éducation nationale la jeunesse de
l'engagement et des sports avec la
rameuse création des draps ges mais qui
permet d'avoir un regard plus en train
d'aider des personnes qui ont un regard
plus générale sur sur ce pôle
ministériel au delà de ça il y avait un
besoin aussi d'interministérialité tout
à l'heure j'ai commencé mes propos sans
presque sans le vouloir mais en citant
et adrien taquet et ma collègue frédéric
vidal c'est bien parce que la jeunesse a
une particularité de transversalité et
donc du coup c'est ce que nous
souhaitons c'est ce que nous avons
expérimenté en allant un peu plus loin
avec même elisabeth bornes sur
ministre du travail sur le plan mentorat
c'est réunir un maximum deux ministères
pour apporter une réponse à la jeunesse
et pas en fonction des champs de me des
ministères concernés
territorialement s'est rassemblée
évidemment dans les jeux d'été des vrais
alliance territoriale plus forte encore
et donc ses actes c'est vraiment état
état collectivités associations et c'est
là où ça revient au mes propos initiaux
sur la place de l'éducation populaire et
l'importance qu'on doit l'importance de
sa place évidemment pour le jeune mais
au delà dans l'organisation de nos
politiques publiques
et ça c'est l'esprit en tout cas
renforcé et souhaité par par le ministre
dans ce cadre là peut-être un dernier
point parce que je pense qu'il est
important quand on travaille sur la
réforme de la formation jeunesse ou
encore sur sur la boussole avec laquelle
la première version de la boussole et et
territoriales c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui elle sur la boussole il y à
40%
il ya 40 aides alors qu'il ya 80 à peu
près nationale donc en première pierre
il n'ya pas encore toutes les aides
territoriales
on avait fait une expérimentation avec
je crois plus d'une part et de me
tromper mais entre dix et douze
territoires qui se sont engagés dans à
mettre les aides pour la jeunesse parce
que c'est une compétence de
collectivités sur un outil permettant de
vente permettant l'accès à tous cette
coordination
même si elle est juste à l'accès à
l'information dans le cadre où je parle
c'est de permettre c'est que ces aides
soient accessibles depuis un lieu unique
dire que le jeune il se pose pas la
question de est-ce que c'est une
politique de l'état une politique de la
collectivité une politique associatif le
plus important c'est que pour lui il est
un point d'entrée et c'était une des
premières
un des premiers engagements de lutte
contre le non recours j'ai essayé de
répondre aux trois points en tout cas
aux différentes structures
merci la présidente monsieur madame
monsieur le président madame la
rapporteure merci à la ministre de faire
partager ces constats c'est vrai qu'ils
sont communs et c'est bien pour ça
c'était l'intérêt de la mission que
senna un mise en place c'est parce que
c'est une acceptable et qu'on essaye
voilà de voir comment les choses
pourraient en être autrement donc vous
nous apportez beaucoup de mesures que
vous faites en transversalité et vous
avez raison avec vos collègues taquet
vidal monsieur blanc caire et d'autres
sûrement parce que faut pas oublier
peut-être monsieur le maire il ya aussi
des questions de finances par derrière
qui sont importantes
bref vous avez parlé du non recours et
c'est vrai que c'était un thème
important développé la semaine dernière
avec le président louis schweitzer qui
il a développé et je voulais vous
demander sur un jeune une solution
est-ce que vous avez parce qu'il a
beaucoup développé le là les verts
contre qu'on connaît dans le travail
social et qui c'est vrai produit ses
fruits lorsque on va au devant de la
personne qui a besoin d'être parce que
souvent pour x raisons elle ne les fait
pas c'est demandé et c'est si l'appel
d'accompagnement donc est-ce que vous
dans le dispositif
un jeune une solution vous pensez que
vous pouvez encore améliorer
[Musique]
c'est ce ces mesures ce dispositif cet
outil parce que les chiffres quand même
ne sont pas au rendez vous madame la
sénatrice en plein milieu de la crise
quand on a quand on a vraiment commencé
à tout consolider les remonter on avait
un jeune sur deux qui ne connaissaient
même pas les aides qui connaissait même
pas le lieu où la personne à qui devait
s'adresser et donc on a consolidé la
grande majorité des expérimentations qui
était en cours de projet d'aller vers en
s'appuyant sur deux deux principaux
acteurs d'une certaine manière
d'abord des acteurs associatifs qui ont
plutôt une qui sont plutôt en avance et
plutôt des acteurs du monde de
l'éducation populaire qui avait cette
culture et donc des pratiques avec avec
une vraie antériorité une vraie
expertise d'aller chercher des jeunes ou
des enfants pour le coup même plus plus
jeune que ça verts ou des projets
éducatifs ou où ça a été le cas sur
vacances apprenantes c'est cela les
verts est absolument nécessaire d'autant
plus que aujourd'hui les portes et par
une partie du collectif mentorat avec
qui on travaille puisque ce on ne peut
pas attendre que les jeunes postule ou
souhaitent avoir un tuteur au mentor est
donc cet accompagnement est dans ce sens
et au delà de ça le renforcement
aujourd'hui du budget humains
d'accompagnement des missions locales
qui sont de vrais acteurs de territoire
et qui aujourd'hui sert porte les
politiques jeunesse mais qui peuvent
avoir une agilité territoriales pour
apporter des réponses d'aller vers
encore plus pertinente ça c'est ce qui
est en cours et d'ailleurs vous avez
raison puisque c'est avec la la ministre
du travail
elisabeth elisabeth bornes que nous
faisons et brigitte klinkert sur
l'insertion en réalité et pour pour
conclure sur sur le sur le et les verts
il va aussi être accéléré d'une certaine
manière grâce aujourd'hui au fait que la
jeunesse soit au sein du périmètre de
l'éducation nationale puisque on
s'appuie maintenant sur la force en fait
des enseignants également qu'ils
identifient et qui par la conjugaison de
l'éducation populaire du goût du monde
associatif socio-éducatif et aujourd'hui
du monde
académique plus facilement accompagné
accompagner socialement et humainement
les jeunes mais on a consolidé les
expérimentations pour pour en train pour
les démultiplier en réalité c'est un
c'est un peu la philosophie qui est la
nôtre ça ne viendra pas tout seul ça
c'est ça c'est réel
et si on veut lutter contre le non
recours est presque des fois contre la
non consommation de dispositifs ou de
projets qui sont plutôt bénéfique
il faut je pense au contraire accentué
et c'est les travaux qui sont en cours
et où je pense je pense que dans
quelques dans quelques mois on pourra
apporter des chiffres pour illustrer ce
qui a été fait et si je peux me
permettre encore une question c'était le
hasard sûrement ce matin dans la presse
locale ouest france faisait état de des
travaux de deux chercheurs qui en
produit une étude sur la ségrégation
scolaire avec une carte je lai sous les
yeux là c'est caricatural de des
collèges ou des lycées de la métropole
nantaise où on retrouve wii de manière
très caricatural et une sur
représentation des catégories socio
professionnelles favorisées dans les
haies les établissements de l'hyper
centre on va dire ça comme ça et puis
publics et privés et donc une sous
représentation dans des
collèges et des lycées d'un vita
quartier type quartier politique de la
ville je sais pas donc si vous avez eu
connaissance et si vous avez rencontré
ces chercheurs mais là aussi ça va dans
le sens alors je sais que là ce n'est
pas dur et les prérogatives de l'état
la carte scolaire que ce soit pour les
collèges et les écoles élémentaires
n'est évidemment pas je demande pas d'un
plu qui ce soir centralisée surtout à
cette période
deux rendez vous électoral mais est-ce
que face au constat qui sont partagés là
encore une fois vous avez des idées ou
des perspectives pour endiguer ce
phénomène qui ne date pas d'hier j'en ai
bien conscience quand je dis ça il peut
être pour compléter la question de
michel si je puis me permettre de parler
des zones urbaines périurbaines mais
qu'en est il pour les zones rurales
merci monsieur présente madame la
sénatrice il se trouve que nous
partageons le même territoire et ma
première lecteurs du matin reste presse
océan et ouest france
nous chez lui j'ai eu connaissance de
j'ai lu j'ai lu cet article je ne
connaissais pas ces chercheurs gelée que
je les connaissais pas par contre la
carte elle est elle inquiétante enfin
elle
certes on pouvait l'imaginer mais le
fait de l'avoir c'est plus et c'est
inquiétant et donc face à la question
non pas de la carte scolaire mais plutôt
de la de la redynamisation de la mixité
sociale pour lutter contre cet égard à
cette ségrégation scolaire il y a deux
tirs deux piliers mais ils sont pas
exhaustifs ils sont pas et c'est pas
c'est pas l'alpha et l'oméga pour lutter
mais le premier d'entre eux c'est
évidemment ce temps fort de projets de
service national mais recèle qui a
vocation vraiment à créer cette mixité
de la faire vivre et pas qu'elle reste
pas que ce soit des mots ou une
politique publique n'ont vécu par les
jeunes ça c'est le premier point et puis
le et puis le deuxième c'est évidemment
les travaux qui sont menés pour le coup
part par le ministre de l'éducation
nationale avec nathalie et limaces qui à
l'éducation prioritaire est bien de
créer
vous savez c'est ces options qui sont un
peu plus particulière qui crée en fait
du mouvement et qui permettent de créer
c
ce brassage et donc de lutter contre la
toux qu'à contrôler les la première
couche pour être juste de la ccravh de
la ségrégation scolaire
au-delà de ces éléments c'est plutôt ma
collègue nathalie et limaces qui
travaille particulièrement sur le sujet
monsieur le président vous avez parlé
des des territoires ruraux
il se trouve que dans mes propos
liminaire j'ai parlé des territoires
août ultramarins mais il se trouve que
dans les travaux que je mène et j'ai la
chance d'être appuyée par l'institut
national de la jeunesse et d'éducation
populaire de l'insep
nous travaillons sur des profils de
terride les jeunes des territoires
ruraux les jeunes également ultra marins
est en réalité les jeunes dans les culs
pv dans les quartiers prioritaires de la
ville et il y à de vraies difficultés
communes et c'est pour ça que par
exemple dans le dans le collectif
mentorat ça me tient à coeur dont c'est
vrai que j'en reparle beaucoup mais dans
le collectif mentorat on est on est
parti chercher des associations qui ont
la connaissance des territoires ruraux
et je pense par exemple à une
association qui s'appelle des
territoires aux grandes écoles qui a une
vraie une vraie expertise une vraie
proposition et au delà de la au-delà
aujourd'hui des expérimentations qui
sont menées tout quasiment tout mais
c'est la nuque c'est vraiment la
philosophie qui portait tout les toutes
les tous les projets des
expérimentations que nous menons sur les
quartiers prioritaires de la ville
aujourd'hui sont ouverts montreal ont
vocation à être ouvrir doit être ouvert
de plus en plus pour les jeunes ruraux
puisque c'est je vais être de mémoire
mais c'est plus de 40% des jeunes de
france les deux piliers j'en ai retenu
qu'un donc c'est la cmu et ensuite c'est
l'accompagnement de l'éducation
nationale pour la question de la
création des des options des parcours
spécifiques des internats d'excellence
et c'est en fait plutôt la mise en
oeuvre du plan égalité des chances avec
est cité est cité éducative et allianz
territoriales ou les options
principalement d'apprentissage des
langues
vous avez cité plusieurs fois le service
national universel
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire où en
es où on est la mise en place est dans
les objectifs fixés quelle serait la
part du service civique et celle des
autres formes de service national
universel
les premiers retours d'expérience les
difficultés de mise en oeuvre d'une
généralisation du fmi et puis de manière
plus concrète
moi j'ai des questions sur
l'organisation matérielle du sn nuit et
notamment les périodes de l'année durant
lesquelles les jeunes devront le
réaliser parce que ça sera pendant les
vacances scolaires est ce que ce sera
pendant la période scolaire parce qu'on
s'est quand même que notamment après
cette période de qu'ovide les temps
scolaires sont particulièrement
contraint et sous quelle forme va se
décliner les missions d'intérêt général
prévue par la seconde phase du sc n'y
voit là ça fait beaucoup de questions
sur le s n y avait qu avec avec plaisir
je vais essayer d'être la plus
exhaustive possible madame la sénatrice
si je prends dans l'ordre la première
expérimentation du service national
universel c'était 2019 si je devais
donner quelques retours d'expérience il
se trouve que un jeune sur deux n'avait
jamais pris le train de toute sa vie qu'
on a identifié presque plus que ce qu'on
imaginait des situations de santé de
prendre des problèmes de santé et même
des problèmes de santé liés à la vue ou
à l'audition qui ont été identifiés on a
au pro la première expérimentation
accueilli 2000 jeunes dans 13
départements 13 départements
c'est là en 2020 nous n'avons pas pu
tenir de séjour de cohésion en dehors de
la nouvelle calédonie qui était sans que
vides donc nous avons réussi à revenir
le seul et unique saison de cohésion là
bas cependant il y avait une partie des
jeunes qui s'étaient engagés qui avait
envie de faire leur mission d'intérêt
général et donc nous avons permis de
l'inversion du calendrier mais de
manière très concrète ils ont pu
s'engager faire
les fameuses 82 heures où les quinze
jours principalement et c'est ce qui
nous a amenés vers un projet service
civique c'est ce que dans les valises
ehpad et autour des personnes âgées et
lui en fait une envie des très jeunes
d'aider les personnes les plus âgées
et donc quand il ya eu cette appétence
alors qu'eux ils ont entre 15 et 17 ans
donc franchement il fallait vraiment
accompagner avec les services
déconcentrés leur leur stage dans des
ehpad ou dans des maisons autonomie vu
cette aspiration avec ma collègue
brigitte bourguignon on a accompagné ce
qu'on appelle le 10000 mission service
civique solidarité seniors permettant à
des jeunes en service civique de vivre
ce lien intergénérationnel et de
l'accompagner que ce soit en autonomie
donc ou en résidence ou encore avec des
associations qui luttent contre l'
isolement je sors du sujet mais c'est
pour illustrer ce qui s'est passé
principalement sur l'année 2020 sur
l'année 2021
nous avons 25 mille jeunes plus de 30
mille candidatures en réalité avec des
profils extrêmement divers on a un tiers
de jeunes urbains un tiers de jeunes
ruraux un tiers de jeunes qui viennent
plutôt du périurbain des jeunes de dons
aux profils familiaux sociaux
professionnels très divers pour le coup
beaucoup plus que sur la première
expérimentation où nous avions plutôt
des jeunes qui venaient de familles
encore en uniforme qui étaient sur
représentés
d'après les études de l'iep l'ensemble
du s est mué en compagne et par des
chercheurs pour pouvoir avoir des
réponses tangibles et puis surtout des
études sur l'idée du parcours
le service national universel est pensé
comme un moment de camp jeudi de creuset
républicain de ce creuset républicain
c'est un temps comme un temps où fait
ensemble un temps où on débat où on
apprend par exemple les gestes de
premiers secours s'orienter utiliser les
outils pour lutter contre le non recours
beaucoup d'informations mais mais dans
une relation moins académique plus en
faisant ça c'est un peu l'esprit
pédagogique qui est fait il est fait
avec les structures d'éducation
populaire avec le monde
monde éducatif donc des enseignants est
également le corps les corps en uniforme
donc c'est principalement alors des
anciens policiers gendarmes pompiers
mais des hommes et des femmes qui ont
porté un uniforme et donc on arrive à
essayer d'avoir à un tiers un tiers un
tiers pour que chacun avec sa culture et
son et est plutôt son regard à porte à
porte aux plus jeunes de manière très
concrète nous avons un encadrement de 1
adulte pour cette jeune
ils ont tous entre 15 et 17 ans
aujourd'hui les centres les centres
d'hébergement sont assez divers on a des
centres de vacances des lycées généraux
ou des lycées agricoles où nous avons
des internats la question du calendrier
va dépendre de l'obligation ou pas
aujourd'hui à 25000 jeunes on reste sur
le temps scolaire est hors temps
scolaire puisque on est encore sur du
volontariat
il n'y a pas d'obligation il n'y aura
pas d'obligation tant qu'il n'y a pas un
débat parlementaire et moelleux les
travaux que je suis en train de mener
c'est d'abord cette expérimentation à
25000 peut-être une expérimentation
d'année prochaine sur un nombre plus
important est évidemment soumettre au
parlement donc au sénat et à l'assemblée
nationale ce projet pour qu'il puisse
être débattu avant une généralisation
totale sur une génération qui a fait
entre 700 milles et huit cent mille
jeunes sur le sur les articulations
mais si on a mis son séjour de cohésion
la règle qui a été posée c'est sortir de
chez soi pour rencontrer d'autres et
donc on ne le vit pas dans son
département on le vit en dehors de son
département
c'est également alors malheureusement
cette année nous avons dû pour des
raisons sanitaires rester sur deûle
intra régional pour sécuriser aussi pour
garantir un maximum les chances de
pouvoir de pouvoir le tenir
l'idée est évidemment d'aller au delà la
première expérimentation la fédé
brassage plus important là on reste
quand même sur sur deûle intrarégional
l'articulation séjour de cohésion mig la
mission d'intérêt général vient après le
séjour des prisons dans l'année elles
durent qu'un jour où 82 heures elle est
principalement portée par alors c'est
assez intéressant
d'abord par le monde associatif et donc
on voit principalement des grandes
fédérations associatives d'éducation
populaire ou de grande solidarité qui
s'engagent à se gérer avec avec envie et
puis également des collectivités des
collectivités de toutes tailles qui sont
en train de développer des missions
d'intérêt général pour permettre à
chaque jeune un trait sur cet âge-là de
vivre un acte de citoyenneté
donc on a là des premières
expérimentations et des décors tirés par
les cadets de la gendarmerie qui ont
adapté leur format haut à la mission
ming les préparation militaire marine ou
désarmé plus les plus généralement les
cadets de la police également qui se
sont engagés dans le dispositif
ou encore et c'est là où c'est l'étape 3
et donc l'étape une c'est ce séjour de
cohésion on va donner de l'information
et lutter contre le fait de ne pas
savoir quelque chose qui existe
l'étape 2 c'est l'engagement donc c'est
le jeune qui s'engage et l'étape 3 qui
est volontaire et qui a vocation à être
entrés entre les 16 et 25 ans du jeune
c'est l'émission d'engagement long et
c'est là où le service civique est la
troisième étape du et ses nus donc en
fait à aucun moment ça vient en
substitution au contraire c'est plutôt
pour permettre en parlant du service
civique en le présentant aux jeunes qui
sont un essai ni leur permettent de
vivre un service un service civique donc
entre 6 et 12 mois en fonction de la
mission est également les mobilités je
pense au corps repères de volontariat ou
très largement l'engagement
bénévole ou l'engagement dans les
réserves qu'elles soient armés aux
forces sécurité intérieure mais
également les chantiers de volontariat
patrimoniaux et donc l'idée si je vais
prendre un peu de seins cher un peu un
peu de recul
c'est pendant ce séjour de cohésion de
faire ensemble d'apprendre peut-être à
plus se connaître de découvrir de
déceler s'il ya des difficultés pour le
jeune et lui apporter une réponse plus
personnel mais également lui donner
toutes les cartes qu'ils puissent
utiliser au moment où il en aura besoin
et donc le service civique arrive à la
fin et c'est pour ça que aujourd'hui
avec l' agence du service civique
on travaille sur les parcours
d'engagement et on dit par exemple à
chaque jeune qui fait un service civique
aujourd'hui les formats européen du
service civique pour ouvrir l'accès aux
mobilités européenne au delà des jeunes
qui sont en étude
ou encore le fait de pouvoir continuer
sur un sur un engagement de volontariat
et ça sera une réussite
s'il y a un temps de mixité sociale
vécue si la mobilité territoriale et
apporte ce goût du de lier et si le
jeune repart avec toutes les cartes et
des apprentissages qu'il pourra
réutiliser au moment lui en aura besoin
madame la sénatrice je ne sais pas si
j'ai répondu à toutes nos questions mais
j'ai essayé de garder le fil normalement
de mes notes et si vous me le permettez
madame la ministre
concrètement comment ça se passe tout ça
donc les étapes successives que vous
avez définies
quand on est une association quand tu
sois du monde de l'éducation populaire
ou pas est-ce qu'il faut passer par les
sacro saints appel à projets est ce
qu'il faut redéfinir tous ces dossiers
qui sont très consommateurs en temps
voilà et d'un bénévolat voilà
concrètement comment est-ce qu'on peut
accéder quand on est une association ou
quand on est une commune aussi de
manière hyper concrète de mer très très
concrète sur le séjour de cohésion donc
la première étape
les associations sont aujourd'hui en
lien avec les services territoriaux et
donc il ya plusieurs expérimentations
soient les structures associatives donc
les animateurs sont dans le centre en
tant qu'acteur encadrants ça c'est le
premier parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
jeunes en bas fa ou une structure
associative qui accueille carrément le
centre et qui le fait de quasiment 2 à z
mais lassé des expérimentations fonction
des territoires et ensuite c'est le
temps des missions d'intérêt général
très concrètement c'est avec les
services déconcentrés il n'y a pas
d'appel à projets il s'est passé pas
l'idée et c'est même les services à
l'intérieur des services des services
déconcentrés ou qu'ils contactent les
collectivités pour développer les
missions d'intérêt général au moment où
au moment où on se parle en
sensibilisant les maires alors parce que
vous m'avez demandé du concret je vous
donnais un calendrier on a commencé
d'abord par les mairies qui accueille
des centres des centres et ses nus
la deuxième phase d'ici la fin de l'été
ça va être toutes les mairies qui ont eu
des jeunes qui sont partis en mission
qui sont partis en séjour de cohésion
parce que c'est à dire que c'est des
jeunes de chez eux qu'ils pourraient
accueillir et là nous avons je vous le
fais de mémoire mais on nous avons que
5000 communes environ qui ont un jeune
qui qui a inscrit et qui va vivre un une
mission d'intérêt général et ensuite
c'est plutôt des des travaux avec les
associations d'élus pour que ça la
possibilité et l'opportunité soit
présenté à l'ensemble des collectivités
qui le souhaiteraient
vous avez évoqué plusieurs fois les
associations d'éducation populaire que
nous avons reçues qui joue depuis très
longtemps un rôle important auprès de la
jeunesse
elles sont toujours très présentes sur
le territoire mais lorsque nous les
avons rencontrés elle ce sont plein
quand même 2 2 comment dire elles ont du
mal à continuer à exister et se sont
notamment plaints et ce ne sont pas les
seuls nous avons encore entendu ce matin
des modes de financement 1 à part appel
à projets qui vraiment plombe alors on
peut comprendre pourquoi ces appels à
projets ont été mis en place en même
temps je pense que il faut les entendre
et il est peut-être temps de commencer à
évoluer sur cette question
[Musique]
les associations d'éducation populaire
avait retrouvé toute leur présence et si
je puis dire toute leur et avait fait
montre de tout leur de toute leur
efficacité dans le dispositif de
modification des rythmes scolaires
votre gouvernement a mis fin
la série de mots scolaire quasiment en
permettant de revenir à la semaine de
quatre jours alors moi je suis d'accord
sur le fait que
la mise en place de cette réforme n'a
pas été la bonne elle a été précipitée
est là elle a demandé aux communes
d'investir beaucoup alors que c'était
une période où les communes
nous étions en pleine crise et les
communes avaient avec peu de moyens et
des baisses importantes de dotation cela
dit plutôt que d'y mettre fin il aurait
peut être mieux valu renforcer les
dispositifs d'éducation populaire donner
des moyens aux communes parce que je
suis certaine que si on avait donné
quelques moyens aux communes
supplémentaires
beaucoup ne renie aurait pas renoncer
telles qu'elles vont telles qu'elles
l'ont fait d'abord la semaine de quatre
jours et demi tous les ceux qui
s'occupent de d'enfance et de petite
enfance dix reconnaissent que les
apprentissages sont quand même plus
facile sur quatre jours et demi que sur
4 jours ce qui paraît assez évident mais
surtout que ce soit en zone urbaine en
zone rurale elle permettait aux enfants
grâce à l'investissement des
associations d'éducation populaire ou
tout simplement d'ailleurs des
engagements d'éducation communal sur les
petites communes de faire connaissance
avec tout un tas de choses auxquelles
auxquels ces enfants n'avaient pas accès
donc moi personnellement je regrette
beaucoup la fin de ce dispositif et
j'aimerais avoir votre avis sur la
question
mais la médiatrice sur le sujet vraiment
rythme scolaire effectivement ça dépend
vraiment du ministère de l'éducation
nationale
mais par contre là où je peux vraiment
apporter un complément c'est sûr c'est
sur la relation aujourd'hui qu'on peut
améliorer avec les structures
d'éducation populaire et pour le coup
effectivement sur la question du rythme
et de la possibilité des collectivités
d'y revenir mais avec voilà le
calendrier qu'on a connu et les réalités
les différences territoriales des uns et
des autres au-delà de ça l'idée est ce
que ce qui est fait actuellement en
train d'être mis en place c'est la
démultiplication des contrats
pluriannuels pour permettre aux
structures d'éducation populaire pour le
coup qui vont dépendre ou de l'éducation
nationale ou de la jeunesse
ne plus avoir à répondre une année après
l'autre et donc on est en train de de
l'exemple de coordonner les calendriers
avec la direction de l'éducation
nationale est de permettre finalement
ces acteurs parce qu'ils répondent ils
répondent à un besoin de l'enfant et
parce que mine serrée en train de
changer et bien de ne pas avoir à le
faire
1 chaque année ou à plusieurs reprises
avec plusieurs interlocuteurs alors que
leurs actions éducatives ou socio
éducative répond à un besoin réel et là
où il ya une opportunité de de renouveau
j'ai fait un si je peux m'exprimer comme
ça c'est que on est parti d'une période
où il y avait beaucoup d'enseignants qui
accompagne et d'écolo pain pendant les
vacances il y avait beaucoup de deux
enseignants engagés dans l'éducation
populaire et puis on a eu une période un
peu de creux ou l'éducation nationale et
l'éducation populaire se sont pris un
peu de distance les uns vis-à-vis des
autres et là la volonté et pour le coup
du ministre c'est aussi de rapprocher et
de faire que ça score donne plus avec la
avec la volonté politique presque de
faire que ça fonctionne mieux et que ça
fonctionne plus d'où le déploiement par
exemple du sc nul avec les acteurs de
l'éducation populaire
le plan mercredi pour permettre ces
activités de loisirs de culture qui
émancipe enfin qui
qui ouvre le champ des polices possibles
dont je parlais tout à l'heure et au
delà de ça ça a été et pour le coup
c'est quelque chose que j'ai mené
personnellement donc ça m'a enfin on
s'est beaucoup investie pendant la crise
vous avez vu il ya beaucoup de centres
de centres de colo qui ont pas pu ouvrir
et qui était vraiment totalement fermés
donc nous avons nous avons lancé un plan
d'urgence de financement de ces
structures
parce qu'elle avait l'habitude de
d'emmener de créer des départs en
vacances pour souvent les jeunes qui ont
le plus besoin d'ailleurs en fonction de
leur âge et grâce à grâce au déploiement
de ce fonds d'urgence porté par le fonds
géré par une structure en tant que tel
on a réussi à accompagner j'essaie de
vous le faire de mémoire mais je crois
que c'était 30 millions d'euros
c'était 30 15 mai 30 c'était ma volonté
c'était 15 millions 15 millions d'euros
que nous avons dès que nous avons réussi
à déployer pour accompagner les
structures avec ou sans hébergement et
surtout je crois que le premier enjeu
c'est que leur énergie ne soit plus dans
les entrées de moins en moins dans les
appels à projets mais sur des plans
pluriannuels et c'est vraiment l'esprit
et des vacances apprenantes et du plan
mercredi et plus largement de la
philosophie du ministère avec le temps
de l'enfant et donc plus de coordination
et plus de co construction entre
l'éducation et d'éducation populaire
toutes les associations les structures
que nous avons rencontrés se sont dit
favorables à un revenu un revenu de
subsistance pour les jeunes de moins de
25 ans nous avions proposé une loi sur
le rsa jeunes pourquoi le rsa jeunes
parce que le rsa existants étant une
mesure existantes il aurait été facile
de le mettre en place malgré malgré tout
pour l'instant cet appel n'est pas
entendu comment l'expliquez vous et j'ai
quand même entendu dernièrement le
président de la république annoncé une
allocation de 500 euros pour les jeunes
de moins de 25 ans mais je ne sais pas
quel type de jeunes est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire plus tout à l'heure
madame la sénatrice nous partageons un
sujet commun c'est-à-dire la situation
de précarité des jeunes qui est qui
s'est accrue durant durant cette crise
qu'il faille aider financièrement les
jeunes qui s'en sortent pas c'est une
évidence et je crois que je ne prends
aucun risque en disant qu'elle est
partagée quelle que soit les bancs et
quelles que soient les sensibilités la
position qui est celle aujourd'hui de du
gouvernement évidemment mettre tous les
moyens nécessaires pour accompagner
financièrement les jeunes qui en ont
besoin mais avec un accompagnement
social constant infor est renforcée
c'est pour ça que il y a eu le
renforcement de la garantie jeunes la
garantie est en nombre déjà permettre à
plus de jeunes de d'en bénéficier et
quasiment c'était 100 mille garantie
jeunes supplémentaires et sans se dire
si on devait en avoir plus de ne pas le
faire de manière assez assez clair ce
qui compte c'est le parcours c'est le
parcours d'insertion qui permet aux
jeunes
finalement de lever toutes les
difficultés qui sont les siennes il ya
aucun tabou sur la question de
l'accompagnement financier des des plus
jeunes et des 18-25 mais en réalité la
garantie je ne sais même dès 16 ans par
contre il fallait élargir et permettre à
des jeunes qui aujourd'hui en sont
exclues de pouvoir en bénéficier
les premières avancées étaient sur la
situation par exemple des parents le
fait qu' on doit prouver son
émancipation pas le fait aussi de
permettre
un accompagnement plus individuelle en
permettant une durée plus longue de la
garantie jeunes parce qu'avec cette idée
des douze mois là on peut aller jusqu'à
18 mois le rsa nous nous apparaissait ne
pas jouer son rôle d'insertion et
d'accompagnement suffisant et c'est pour
ça que les travaux aujourd'hui du
gouvernement sont sur l'élargissement
encore plus fort de la garantie jeunes
qui à qui un magnifique dispositif qui
réussit de la levée en fait toutes les
difficultés dont on parlait tout à
l'heure en fin au tout début de nous de
cette audition les questions de logement
d'accès à la santé de non recours au
droit et c'est pour ça que que ce soit
aujourd'hui un jeune de 15 de 16 ans de
17 ans de 18 ans s'il a besoin de cette
aide financière
il a aussi d'autres besoins et de
renforcer l'accompagnement humain était
une priorité
et donc c'est le sait la ligne enfin
c'est la ligne
le chemin que nous prenons donc c'est
pas un tabou la question du rsa ou la
question d'apporter une réponse à minima
de 500 euros à chaque jeune
cette réponse à l'instant on se parle
c'est la garantie jeunes élargie et qui
a vocation encore à s'élargir
dès le mois de novembre j'avais j'avais
saisi le coche ce que je pense qu'une
aide comme ça doit se construire avec
les acteurs de la jeunesse le chemin
évident et c'est lui suite au rapport du
coche et de monsieur bien que nous avons
avec elisabeth bornes commencé à
travailler à son élargissement sans
aucun frein financier
à l'instant où on se parle très bien
mot sur l'aspect fossé numérique je
pense que vous l'avez évoqué madame la
ministre donc ici dans cette mission on
a eu des auditions sur ce sujet là
encore comment est ce qu'on explique la
jeunesse ont toutes un point commun
c'est qu'elles ont un équipement mobile
équipements mais qu'elles sont et qu'ils
lisent pas de la même manière elles
n'ont pas toutes les mêmes codes donc là
dessus qu'est ce que votre ministère
quand développer là effectivement il ya
en fait il ya un vrai tabou enfin il est
presque un malaise l'électronicien de la
jeunesse c'est pas c'est pas un fantasme
c'est une vraie réalité et il est mais
exactement et en fait on a l'habitude de
penser aux personnes âgées on a
l'habitude d'adresser des réponses
d'accompagnement demain ou
d'accompagnement spécifique aux plus
âgés ont dix ans c'est normal mais en
réalité les plus jeunes sont sont face à
cette fracture numérique qui qui
s'accroît et donc ce que nous sommes en
train de ce que nous sommes en train de
faire c'est d'accompagner à chaque fois
qu'un dispositif numérique typiquement
je pense aux un jeune d'une solution la
boussole la pensée humaine et la pensée
de l'accompagnement par une personne
pour un chemin vers plus d'autonomie au
numérique
il ya évidemment le renforcement des
projets pédagogiques avec un plan
numérique portée par le ministre est
donc c'est tout l'enseignement mais
c'est aussi aujourd'hui des programmes
comme ça montrait en train de travailler
enfin c'est pas pour sauver le
rapporteur mais avec le monde de
l'éducation populaire parce que sur ses
temps scolaire et périscolaire
on peut acquérir de nouvelles
compétences de nouveaux outils et c'est
une chance et donc on profite également
de leur expertise pour donner les moyens
de s'en sortir en tout cas les premières
quasiment les premiers outils par un
premier secours on peut retrouver son
son chemin parce que c'est doublement
nécessaire quand on est avec frédéric
vidal en train de développer quatre ans
29 campus connecter pour lutter contre
ces inégalités d'offres d'accès à la
formation
il faut cependant d'accompagnement à
l'accès à ces outils numériques est
cette année de crise a montré à quel
point le manque d'outils dire
aujourd'hui c'est pas vrai tous les
jeunes n'ont pas un ordinateur tous les
jeunes n'ont pas accès à une connexion
internet de qualité
par contre tous les jeunes ont un
smartphone sauf qu'on n'étudie pas sur
un smartphone on n'a pas accès ou c'est
extrêmement difficile de répondre à des
formulaires d'être sur un smartphone et
donc ça crée une sorte de barrière est
donc ce smartphone il ya l'éducation à
l'information pour l'utiliser donc pour
protéger aussi les jeunes parce que
c'est pas pour rentrer de sur d'autres
sujets mais aujourd'hui la question
défectueuse du harcèlement c'est une
éducation et c'est une éducation qui est
nécessaire et plus vite puisque les
smartphones se retrouve très vite entre
les mains des enfants
enfin jeudi des enfants parce que il ya
quelques à peine quelques années je veux
dire on était assez naturellement un
code à la télé enfin moi j'ai connu en
tout cas un code à la télé enfin sur la
télé et oui un code parental ou sur
l'ordinateur et alors qu'un smartphone
en fête permet plus de choses encore
qu'un ordinateur ou une télé et en fait
on l'a pas donc ça c'est des travaux qui
sont en cours
et aujourd'hui on renforce et c'est ce
qu'ont fait principalement l'éducation
aux médias avec énormément d'acteurs
d'éducation populaire qui se sont saisis
de ces deals 7
enfin le mot est fort mais je crois que
c'est un fléau parce que y
ça amène malheureusement en tout cas en
tout cas au pire donc très concrètement
politiques publiques systématiquement
accompagnée d'un vin d'un pilotage et
d'une politique humaine et là je pense
par exemple aux ados maison francs
service où nous sommes en train de
travailler pour coordonner le réseau
d'information jeunesse avec la présence
de jeunes par exemple en service civique
ou de jeunes en contrats du coup premier
contrat pour permettre ce lien de pair à
pair qui est facilitée et donc et penser
tous ces espaces où nous imaginons
faciliter l'accès aux plus âgés le
permettre aussi aux plus jeunes avec la
présence de personne pour l'accompagner
sur le modèle un petit peu d'émissions
numérique
j'espère que j'ai pas été trop long
après ça
[Musique]
très bien
si nos collègues présents des questions
pain je peux conclure les travaux
notamment nos collègues bargeton estang
jeunes qui sont présents en visio sinon
si ce n'est pas le cas il n'y a pas
d'autres questions en tout cas je vous
remercie même la ministre
[Musique]